Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Put yourself in his place and let the white man ask himself this question. What would I do if threatened as the Indian has been and is? Suppose a race superior to mine were to land upon the shores of this great continent, trade or cheat us out of our land foot by foot, gradually encroach upon our domain until we were finally driven, a degraded, demoralized band
保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。设身处地想一想，让白人问自己这个问题：如果我像印第安人过去和现在所受到的威胁那样，我会怎么做？假设一个比我优越的种族降临到这片伟大大陆的海岸上，一寸一寸地通过贸易或欺诈夺走我们的土地，逐渐侵占我们的领地，直到我们最终被驱赶，成为一群堕落、士气低落的群体，
into a small corner of the continent, where to live at all it was necessary to steal? Perhaps to do worse? What would we do? I have seen one who hates an Indian as he does a snake, and thinks there is no good Indian but a dead one. On having the proposition put to him in this way, grind his teeth in rage and exclaim, I would cut the heart out of everyone I could lay my hand on. And so he would. And so we all would. Dominic, that was Colonel John Gibbon. Yes. Who was the commander of Fort Ellis, which was the army base in Montana on the Bozeman Trail, indisputably the top trail.
被赶到大陆的一个小角落，为了生存不得不去偷窃？甚至做更坏的事？我们会怎么做？我见过一个人，他像恨蛇一样恨印第安人，认为只有死掉的印第安人才是好印第安人。当有人这样向他提出这个问题时，他愤怒地咬牙切齿，大喊道：我会挖出我能抓到的每一个人的心脏。他确实会这么做。我们所有人也都会这么做。多米尼克，那是约翰·吉本（John Gibbon）上校。是的。他是埃利斯堡（Fort Ellis）的指挥官，那是蒙大拿州博兹曼小径（Bozeman Trail）上的陆军基地，毫无疑问是顶级小径。
And he was writing to the Army and Navy Journal in December 1875. So that is a few short months before the Battle of the Little Bighorn. And he himself, John Gibbon, will be playing a part in that campaign. So again, it's this kind of something that we've highlighted several times in this series, the way in which those soldiers who are taking the lead in the war against the Plains Indians are entirely cognizant of why they are fighting, of why the peoples that they are being told to go and pen into a reservation, why they might not want to be penned into a reservation. Yeah, absolutely. There's sort of dark irony of it.
他在1875年12月写信给《陆军和海军杂志》（Army and Navy Journal）。那是在小大角战役（Battle of the Little Bighorn）前短短几个月。而他本人，约翰·吉本，也将在那场战役中扮演重要角色。所以，这再次印证了我们在本系列中多次强调的一点：那些在对平原印第安人的战争中担任领导角色的士兵，完全清楚他们为何而战，也完全清楚为什么他们被告知要去驱赶的人民，可能并不想被关进保留地。是的，绝对是这样。这其中有一种黑暗的讽刺意味。
So, Tom, Colonel John Gibbon, from that reading, has the voice of Leonard Nimoy. Is that what you were aiming for? Yes. I mean, I think that there is something very Captain Kirk about Custer. Do you? Don't you think? I think Captain Kirk is a more decent man than Custer deep down. Don't you?
那么，汤姆，刚才朗读中约翰·吉本上校的声音是伦纳德·尼莫伊（Leonard Nimoy）的风格。这是你想要的效果吗？是的。我的意思是，我觉得卡斯特（Custer）身上确实有一种柯克船长（Captain Kirk）的特质。你觉得呢？你不觉得吗？我觉得柯克船长内心深处比卡斯特更正派。你不觉得吗？
Yeah, possibly. But there is very much, you know, the you mustn't intrude into alien planets and Kirk immediately goes down and intrudes. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So there's a slight quality of that. So I like to think of John Gibbon as the rational, cool, measured sidekick. Right. Okay.
嗯，可能吧。但确实有那种“你绝不能闯入外星行星”的感觉，而柯克总是直接降落并闯入。是的，完全正确。完全正确。所以确实有那么一点特质。所以我喜欢把约翰·吉本看作是那个理性、冷静、有分寸的搭档。对。好的。
That was the thinking that I brought. Obviously, I have no idea what he sounded like. Right. Okay. That was the thinking that I brought. Obviously, I have no idea what he sounded like. Yeah. I imagine, surely an enormous beard at the very least, Tom. Yeah, he did have a big beard.
这就是我带来的想法。显然，我不知道他听起来是什么样。对。好的。这就是我带来的想法。显然，我不知道他听起来是什么样。是的。我想，至少他肯定留着巨大的胡子，汤姆。是的，他确实留着大胡子。
So, you're absolutely right. At that very moment that he's writing those words, his superiors are drawing up a secret plan to strike at the Plains Indians, the indigenous people who have now moved on
所以，你说得完全正确。就在他写下这些话的那一刻，他的上级正在制定一个秘密计划，旨在打击平原印第安人，那些现在已经迁徙到
to the Plains, the Lakota and so on. And Gibbon, as the commander of Montana, will be at the heart of that operation. So for those people who are actually still with us on this series, who began 84 episodes ago. Yeah, on the Great Bozeman Trail, that is our series. You will recall that in the last episode, Custer had gone on an expedition to the Black Hills. And there, there had been great exaggerated claims that they had found gold. And in the aftermath of the expedition, loads of miners and settlers and adventurers and kind of rogues and entrepreneurs have their eyes on the Black Hills and are keen to move in and indeed have started
平原上的原住民，拉科塔人（Lakota）等等。而作为蒙大拿州的指挥官，吉本将处于该行动的核心。所以，对于那些从84集前就开始追这个系列的听众朋友们。是的，关于伟大的博兹曼小径，这就是我们的系列节目。你们会记得，在上一集中，卡斯特去黑山（Black Hills）进行了一次探险。在那里，有传言称他们发现了黄金，这些说法被极大地夸大了。探险结束后，大量的矿工、定居者、冒险家以及各种流氓和企业家都盯上了黑山，渴望搬进去，事实上也已经开始
to move in, impelled not least by the fact that the United States has entered a depression after the panic of 1873. Now, meanwhile, you'll also remember that last time we talked about how for Sitting Bull, for Crazy Horse and the other non-treaty Lakota, so who've not agreed to go on a reservation, they feel that the storm clouds are gathering for them, Tom, aren't they? In the east. Yes. Storm clouds always gather to the east. That's the way history works.
搬进去了，这在很大程度上是因为美国在1873年恐慌后陷入了经济萧条。现在，与此同时，你们也记得上次我们谈到，对于坐牛（Sitting Bull）、疯马（Crazy Horse）和其他非条约拉科塔人来说，也就是那些不同意进入保留地的人，他们感到风暴云正在向他们聚集，汤姆，不是吗？在东方。是的。风暴云总是从东方聚集。历史就是这样运作的。
They are alarmed by the advance of the railroads, by the advance of these settlers, but also the pressures on the bison, because all the time, of course, hundreds of thousands of buffalo are being massacred. So their lifestyle is coming under great pressure. Sitting Bull has had a sun dance with the Cheyenne to bring them into alliance.
他们对铁路的推进、定居者的推进感到惊恐，同时也对野牛面临的压力感到担忧，因为当然，成千上万的野牛一直在被屠杀。所以他们的生活方式正承受着巨大的压力。坐牛与夏延人（Cheyenne）举行了太阳舞（Sun Dance），以促成他们之间的联盟。
And he ended that by saying, if you remember, the great spirit has given our enemy into our power. So there's a kind of expectation, I think. Would you go so far as to say that the drumbeat of war is sounding? Drums are pounding. The battle rhythm is being pounded out, Tom. Starting to pulse. It is pulsing.
他最后说，如果你们还记得的话，伟大的神灵已经把我们的敌人交到了我们手中。所以，我想有一种期待。你会说战争的鼓声已经敲响了吗？鼓声在敲击。战斗的节奏正在被敲打出来，汤姆。开始跳动了。它在跳动。
It absolutely is. Because we entered the last episode with a tremendous cliffhanger of Ulysses S. Grant, the president, calling a secret meeting at the White House to decide what they're going to do on the 3rd of November, 1875. And he has General Sheridan there, Philip Sheridan, two feet tall, very pugnacious. General Crook, Indian fighter, an old Indian hand. Kind of two-pronged beard. Yeah, with peculiar beard. Angry badger.
绝对是这样。因为我们在上一集的结尾留下了一个巨大的悬念：尤利西斯·S·格兰特（Ulysses S. Grant）总统于1875年11月3日在白宫召开了一次秘密会议，决定他们要做什么。谢里登将军（General Sheridan）也在场，菲利普·谢里登，个子不高，非常好斗。克鲁克将军（General Crook），印第安人斗士，一位老练的印第安事务专家。留着分叉的胡子。是的，留着奇怪的胡子。愤怒的獾。
Exactly. They're there. And there's the guy from the Bureau of Indian Affairs. There is the interior, a secretary, Zachariah Chandler. There is the secretary of war, William Belknap. So these are kind of Grant's intimates. And at this meeting, they draw up an extremely cold-blooded plan. The plan is, first of all, we will not enforce anymore the edicts
没错。他们都在那里。还有来自印第安事务局的人。内政部长扎卡里亚·钱德勒（Zachariah Chandler）也在。还有战争部长威廉·贝尔纳普（William Belknap）。所以这些都是格兰特的亲信。在这次会议上，他们制定了一个极其冷血的计划。计划是，首先，我们将不再执行那些
against stopping settlers coming to the Black Hills. So we won't repeal them, we won't cancel them, but we just won't enforce them anymore let them go in and in fact if the lakota retaliate against the white trespassers as they are likely to do brilliant that's what we want that's the casus belli exactly we want a provocation and secondly to make sure we absolutely get a provocation we will give the lakota the non-treaty lakota so sitting bull and co the people who have not gone to the reservation we will give the Lakota, the non-treaty Lakota, so Sitting Bull and Co, the people who have not gone to the reservation, we will give them an ultimatum effectively. We will give them a deadline. They must report to their agencies on the reservation. When is it,
阻止定居者进入黑山的法令。所以我们不会废除它们，也不会取消它们，我们只是不再执行它们，让他们进去。事实上，如果拉科塔人对白人入侵者进行报复，就像他们很可能会做的那样，太棒了，这正是我们想要的，这就是战争借口（casus belli）。没错，我们需要一个挑衅。其次，为了确保我们绝对能得到一个挑衅，我们将给拉科塔人，那些非条约拉科塔人，也就是坐牛和他的同伙，那些没有去保留地的人，我们将给他们一个最后通牒。我们将给他们一个截止日期。他们必须向保留地上的代理机构报到。是什么时候，
Tom? It's in the dead of winter, isn't it? The 31st of January. Yes. And so the whole point is that the Great Plains are buried in snow at this point, so they won't be able to get there. You don't move in winter. You hunker down. So they believe that this will provide them the pretext that they want for war so that they can move in and take the Black Hills. Now, what is more, Tom, they leak a few days later a report, a sexed up intelligence report by an inspector from the Indian Bureau called E.C. Watkins. Nathaniel Philbrick says Watkins, a former Republican Party hack from Michigan who had served under Sheridan during the Civil War. In other words, somebody who can be absolutely guaranteed to give the administration what it wants. So there is a lot of speaking with forked tongues going on, it would be fair to say.
汤姆？是在严冬，对吧？1月31日。是的。所以重点是，大平原此时被积雪覆盖，所以他们根本无法到达那里。你不会在冬天搬家。你会躲起来。所以他们相信这将为他们想要的战争提供借口，这样他们就可以进入并夺取黑山。而且，汤姆，几天后他们泄露了一份报告，一份由印第安事务局的一名检查员E.C.沃特金斯（E.C. Watkins）撰写的、经过修饰的情报报告。纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克（Nathaniel Philbrick）说，沃特金斯是密歇根州的一名前共和党政客，曾在内战期间在谢里登手下服役。换句话说，是一个绝对可以保证给政府提供其想要内容的人。所以可以说，这里有很多口是心非的事情在发生。
Absolutely, Tom. So this inspector, he says in his report, Sitting Bull is causing havoc. He and his friends are roaming around killing white people. They richly merit punishment for their incessant warfare. They should be whipped into subjection. The government owes it to civilization and the common cause of humanity to strike back. And Dominic, just to reiterate, this is not true. No. They are not going around inflicting... I mean, I don't want us to fall into the trap of idealizing the indigenous people. No, but I think we've been very upfront about the whole testicle slashing and eye gouging
绝对是这样，汤姆。所以这位检查员在报告中说，坐牛正在制造混乱。他和他的朋友们四处游荡，杀害白人。他们因不断的战争而罪有应得。他们应该被鞭打至屈服。政府有义务为了文明和人类的共同事业进行反击。多米尼克，再次重申，这不是真的。不。他们并没有四处造成……我的意思是，我不想让我们陷入理想化原住民的陷阱。不，但我认为我们已经非常坦率地谈论了拉科塔人和夏延人中存在的一些割睾丸和挖眼睛的
tendencies that some of the Lakota and the Cheyenne have, but they've behaved well. I mean, they do not want war. No, they don't. They absolutely don't. They just want to be left alone. And this is a trumped up charge. It is a mendacious report with a trumped up charge. There's no doubt about that at all. So now that they've got the report, they send Zachariah Chana, the interior secretary. I mean, the funny thing is, I remember reading about this bloke when I was a student because of Reconstruction.
倾向，但他们表现得很好。我的意思是，他们并不想要战争。不，他们不想要。他们绝对不想要。他们只是想被单独留下来。这是一个捏造的指控。这是一份充满谎言的报告，带有捏造的指控。这一点毫无疑问。所以现在他们拿到了报告，他们派出了内政部长扎卡里亚·钱德勒。我的意思是，有趣的是，我记得我还是学生时读过这个家伙，因为重建时期（Reconstruction）。
He was an abolitionist. He was one of the founders of the Republican Party. In the books about Reconstruction- He's a hero. He's a good guy. He's one of the good guys. But in this context, that's what makes it so morally interesting. In this context, he's unequivocally a snake. So he sends the message, come to the agencies. They obviously are not going to do that. And funnily enough, they say, well, we'll maybe come in the spring. And of course, the administration says, no good. And they give the green light to General Sheridan. Okay, great. They're not going to turn up. Let's do
他曾是一名废奴主义者。他是共和党的创始人之一。在关于重建的书里——他是英雄。他是好人。他是好人之一。但在这种背景下，这正是让他变得如此道德上有趣的原因。在这种背景下，他显然是一条毒蛇。所以他发出了信息，来代理机构吧。他们显然不会那样做。有趣的是，他们说，好吧，我们也许春天会来。当然，政府说，不行。他们给谢里登将军开了绿灯。好的，太棒了。他们不会出现的。让我们做
this. Let's prepare for war. And Sheridan loves the winter campaign, doesn't he? He does. Winter campaigns are really his thing. So Sheridan, like his boss, General Sherman, as people will remember, they made their name in the Civil War when they'd been famous for these really, really ruthless scorched earth campaigns. Demonstrations of total war. Total war, exactly. So Sheridan says, what I want to do is I want to get this guy, General Terry, to march westwards from the Dakotas. So General Terry, he has a good beard.
这件事。让我们为战争做准备。谢里登喜欢冬季战役，不是吗？他确实喜欢。冬季战役确实是他的拿手好戏。所以谢里登，就像他的老板谢尔曼将军（General Sherman）一样，正如人们所记得的那样，他们在内战中成名，因为他们以这些非常、非常无情的焦土政策战役而闻名。全面战争的示范。全面战争，没错。所以谢里登说，我想做的是，我想让这个家伙，特里将军（General Terry），从达科他州向西进军。所以特里将军，他有一把好胡子。
He looks like Dickens. An extraordinary beard. Yeah, very impressive beard. I struggle with General Terry because when I first came across him, when I first read Nathaniel Philbrickick's book which was about 15 years ago the only terry i really knew was john terry oh yes he was very much in his pomp yes the personally charming yeah former chelsea captain incredibly amiable man by all accounts john terry always popping up in photographs photobombing wasn't he yeah lifted the european cup in full, despite having not played in the match.
他看起来像狄更斯。一把非凡的胡子。是的，非常令人印象深刻的胡子。我很难把特里将军和别人联系起来，因为当我第一次遇到他时，当我第一次读纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克的书时，那大约是15年前，我真正知道的唯一的特里是约翰·特里（John Terry）。哦，是的，他当时正处于巅峰时期。是的，个人很有魅力，是的，前切尔西队长，据所有人的说法都是一个非常和蔼可亲的人。约翰·特里总是出现在照片里，抢镜，不是吗？是的，在没有参加比赛的情况下，完整地举起了欧洲冠军杯。
Anyway, that's by the by. But I struggle with General Terry because he seems to have been a very smooth, affable, intelligent man. And those are not things that have ever been applied to John Terry. Well, I think of him as being called Terry. That's his Christian name. Yeah. Do you know Terry?
总之，那是题外话。但我很难把特里将军和别人联系起来，因为他似乎是一个非常圆滑、和蔼、聪明的人。而这些词从来没有被用在约翰·特里身上。嗯，我想他被称为特里。那是他的教名。是的。你认识特里吗？
Oh, hello, Terry. Like Terry and June. Like Terry Scott. Let's have Terry and June round for Sherry. This is meaningless. There may be some Americans listening to this, Tom. Who knows what they're thinking? Never has John Terry made it into a podcast about...
哦，你好，特里。就像《特里和琼》（Terry and June）。就像特里·斯科特（Terry Scott）。让我们请特里和琼过来喝雪利酒吧。这毫无意义。可能有一些美国人在听这个，汤姆。谁知道他们在想什么？约翰·特里从来没有出现在关于……的播客中。
Yeah, but I mean, Terry is a name, an American name. It's just that, you know, General Bob. I guess so. You could be General Keith, couldn't you? General Jim. Anyway, listen. Yes. He's a smart, intelligent kind of, he's not like Custer.
是的，但我的意思是，特里是一个名字，一个美国名字。只是，你知道，基思将军（General Keith），不是吗？吉姆将军（General Jim）。总之，听着。是的。他是一个聪明、睿智的人，他不像卡斯特。
He's a desk general, isn't he really, General Terry? Yeah. He's us, let's be honest. Yeah. He likes doing a bit of paperwork. He likes hanging out on paddle steamers, doesn't he? Rather than getting in the saddle. He does.
他是个文职将军，不是吗，特里将军？是的。他就是我们，老实说。是的。他喜欢做点文书工作。他喜欢在明轮船上闲逛，不是吗？而不是骑马。他确实如此。
Having fine wines. I imagine him having, he has like white tablecloths on his paddle steamer and yeah, all that. Which I think is much more off-hype than rushing around in buckskin, I'm going to be honest. So actually, as soon as he sets out, he says, oh, the weather's terrible. Lots of snow. Oh, awful temperature. I'm not going to bother doing this. And he goes back to his fort.
喝着好酒。我想象他有，他的明轮船上有白色的桌布，是的，所有这些。我觉得这比穿着鹿皮到处乱跑要高雅得多，老实说。所以实际上，他一出发就说，哦，天气太糟糕了。雪很大。哦，温度太可怕了。我不打算费心做这件事了。然后他就回到了他的堡垒。
The guy you started with, Gibbon, Colonel Gibbon, he's meant to be coming the other way. So from Montana east. And he says, yeah, a lot of snow, no good. So that leaves just one guy, General Crook, with his tremendous forked beard. He sort of struggles through the snow. His campaign is a complete disaster. They basically just, all they do is they attack a Cheyenne village,
你开始提到的那个家伙，吉本，吉本上校，他本应该从另一个方向来。也就是从蒙大拿州向东。他说，是的，雪很大，不行。所以只剩下一个人，克鲁克将军，留着他那巨大的分叉胡子。他算是挣扎着穿过了雪地。他的战役完全是一场灾难。他们基本上只是，他们所做的只是袭击了一个夏延人的村庄，
Powder River. That achieves nothing at all. But what it does do- Has a chain effect, doesn't it? Because they go and meet Crazy Horse. Correct. It pushes the Cheyenne. They're sort of refugees.
粉河（Powder River）。那什么也没实现。但它确实做到了——有连锁反应，不是吗？因为他们去见了疯马。正确。它推动了夏延人。他们算是难民。
Their village has been burned. They go to Crazy Horse's village. Crazy Horse's village is not big enough to accommodate them. But he's still incredibly generous because Crazy Horse, as well as being a great warrior, is a man of immense generosity, Dom. You love Crazy Horse, don't you, Tom? I do love Crazy Horse. So they all move now to Sitting Bull's village. So at this point, Sitting Bull's village has swollen well beyond the level
他们的村庄被烧毁了。他们去了疯马的村庄。疯马的村庄不够大，容纳不下他们。但他仍然非常慷慨，因为疯马不仅是一位伟大的战士，而且是一个极其慷慨的人，多姆。你喜欢疯马，不是吗，汤姆？我确实喜欢疯马。所以他们现在都搬到了坐牛的村庄。所以此时，坐牛的村庄已经膨胀到远远超过了
that it was at the beginning of the year because of this shambolic winter campaign fought by General Crook. well beyond the level that it was at the beginning of the year because of this shambolic winter campaign fought by General Crook. And Sitting Bull, they have a big council. Sitting Bull welcomes the newcomers and he says to them, look, we are not going to go out and fight the Americans. That's madness. We'll fight if they attack us, but for the moment moment we will bide our time we will just sort of hunker down and and wait to see what the spring brings and by sort of spring comes the numbers have really swollen in this village they're now up to about 3 000 people which is far more than is the norm yeah and that any of the americans are expecting and this is of course their own winter campaign
年初的水平，因为克鲁克将军发动的这场混乱的冬季战役。远远超过了年初的水平，因为克鲁克将军发动的这场混乱的冬季战役。而坐牛，他们举行了一个大型会议。坐牛欢迎了新来者，他对他们说，看，我们不会出去和美国人打仗。那是疯狂。如果他们攻击我们，我们会反击，但目前我们先按兵不动，我们先躲起来，看看春天会带来什么。到了春天，这个村庄的人数确实膨胀了，现在大约有3000人，这远远超过了正常水平，是的，也远远超过了任何美国人的预期。当然，这完全是他们自己的冬季战役
that has done this. It's like dropping a snowball down the side of a mountain, isn't it? And watching it slowly get larger and larger. It is. Although, of course, they're not watching it. I think that's a really key point, that their intelligence throughout, either it's not very good or when it is good, they don't listen to it. I think that they just don't think it's possible.
造成的。这就像把一个雪球从山坡上滚下来，不是吗？看着它慢慢变得越来越大。确实是。虽然，当然，他们并没有在看。我认为这是一个非常关键的点，他们的情报始终要么不太好，要么即使很好，他们也不听。我认为他们只是觉得这不可能。
I think that they're operating under a kind of an assumption, oh, they're all savages, we don't need to worry about them. Yes, I totally agree. You know, we can whop them whenever we want. We just don't even need to keep an eye on them. They do, I totally agree with you. I think running through this whole thing, and it's familiar to us, I think, because we have grown up
我认为他们是在一种假设下运作，哦，他们都是野蛮人，我们不需要担心他们。是的，我完全同意。你知道，我们想什么时候打败他们就什么时候打败他们。我们甚至不需要盯着他们。他们确实如此，我完全同意你的看法。我认为贯穿这一切的，这对我们来说很熟悉，我想，因为我们从小就
reading so many stories about British imperial failures that were born of massively underestimating. Huge complacency. Total complacency and racial arrogance. And this is exactly the same kind of thing. So meanwhile, General Sheridan, who is based in Chicago, he says, oh, the winter campaign hasn't worked out. Well, I suppose we'll have to have a summer campaign. And now you may say, why isn't this guy who is an extremely practiced and experienced general, one of the great stars of the civil war, why doesn't he lead it himself?
读过很多关于英国帝国失败的故事，这些失败源于极度的低估。巨大的自满。完全的自满和种族傲慢。这完全是同样的事情。所以与此同时，驻扎在芝加哥的谢里登将军说，哦，冬季战役没有成功。好吧，我想我们必须进行一次夏季战役。现在你可能会问，为什么这个经验极其丰富、久经沙场的将军，内战中的大明星之一，为什么他不亲自领导呢？
And there's an interesting reason here, which is actually, I love these examples of the way in which one issue kind of has a knock-on effect on another. So the reason that he doesn't go is because his boss, General Sherman, says to him, listen, I may need you because all of the time that we've been telling this story, the argument about Reconstruction has been going on in the former Confederate South, the former slave states. And at this point in the 1870s, the South is, to use the language of the time, is being, in inverted commas,
这里有一个有趣的原因，实际上，我喜欢这些例子，说明一个问题如何对另一个问题产生连锁反应。他不去的理由是，他的老板谢尔曼将军对他说，听着，我可能需要你，因为在我们讲述这个故事的所有时间里，关于重建的争论一直在前南方邦联、前蓄奴州进行。而在1870年代的这一点上，南方，用当时的话说，正在被，用引号括起来，
redeemed, meaning that the old Southern kind of white supremacists are very close to recapturing control of the South. There is a big upsurge, 1874, 1875, in paramilitary violence. The Klan itself has been suppressed, but its groups are very like the Klan. They are carrying out all this terrorist violence against Republicans, against the black freedmen, and so on and so forth. And Sheridan and Sherman, who are very much opposed to this kind of behavior, are thinking, we need some army strength and we need some of our best commanders in case they have to go down to Louisiana or Mississippi to restore order.
“救赎”（redeemed），意味着旧南方的白人至上主义者非常接近重新夺回对南方的控制。1874年、1875年，准军事暴力激增。三K党本身已被镇压，但其团体非常像三K党。他们正在对共和党人、黑人自由民等进行所有这些恐怖暴力活动。而谢里登和谢尔曼，他们非常反对这种行为，他们认为，我们需要一些军队力量，我们需要我们最好的指挥官，以防他们必须去路易斯安那州或密西西比州恢复秩序。
So Sheridan can't go himself. But he says, that's fine. I have total confidence in my subordinates. Among whom is Custer. So what is Custer's role in all this? It's complicated, isn't it? Yeah, because Custer has actually been back in New York. And Custer, Tom, well, Custer's been disgracing himself.
所以谢里登不能亲自去。但他表示，没关系。我对我的下属有充分的信心。其中就有卡斯特。那么卡斯特在这一切中扮演什么角色呢？很复杂，不是吗？是的，因为卡斯特实际上一直待在纽约。而且卡斯特，汤姆，嗯，卡斯特一直在丢脸。
Because, of course, Custer is on the wrong side of that political argument. Custer has always been a Democrat. Custer is a very outspoken critic of the Grant administration and of Reconstruction. And I think he is emboldened a bit because he thinks the Grant administration is coming to an end and the Democrats are on the way back. Yeah. And so this is a political equivalent of charging a line and hoping that he will smash into it at just the time as it's kind of ready to collapse. Yeah. And he needs, what Custer wants, I think, is that Custer thinks the last few years, there have been highs and lows, but it's been a lot of drift and I haven't really got the position that I want. But maybe if I get through to the end of 1876 with a new administration and so on that are friendly to me, and if I could make myself a star with some great coup on the frontier, things could look up for me.
因为，当然，卡斯特站在了那个政治争论的错误一边。卡斯特一直是一名民主党人。卡斯特是格兰特政府和重建政策的直言不讳的批评者。而且我认为他有点胆大妄为，因为他认为格兰特政府即将结束，民主党即将回归。是的。所以这在政治上相当于冲锋陷阵，希望在它准备崩溃的时候撞进去。是的。而且他需要，卡斯特想要的是，我认为卡斯特认为过去几年，有起有落，但有很多漂泊，我并没有真正得到我想要的位置。但也许如果我能熬到1876年底，有一个新的政府等等，他们对我友好，如果我能在边境上通过某种伟大的政变让自己成为明星，事情可能会好转。
So he still dreams of becoming a kind of New York bigwig. And he's doing an awful lot of speculating. Right. So he's hoping for military success. He's hoping for political success so that if he takes on the Grant administration now and that then gets replaced, then the new administration might be grateful to him. And he's looking for ways to get rich. Yeah, he is. It's a three-pronged kind of... Yeah. He's doing this thing called short selling. You borrow a share from somebody,
所以他仍然梦想成为纽约的大人物。而且他做了大量的投机。对。所以他希望获得军事上的成功。他希望获得政治上的成功，这样如果他现在挑战格兰特政府，而政府随后被取代，那么新政府可能会对他心存感激。而且他正在寻找致富的方法。是的，他是。这是一种三管齐下的……是的。他正在做一种叫做卖空（short selling）的事情。你从某人那里借入股票，
you sell it, you hope the price goes down, then you buy it back and you give it back to the person you borrowed it from, but you hope you've made a profit in the meantime. It's very risky. Shorting. You short things, don't you? Exactly. You short things. It's very risky. He loses a lot of money. He carries out, Tom, $400,000 worth of trades in this period, which is an extraordinary figure. Which is a lot of money then isn't it yes so the way you do it is you try to make sure you're not going to lose too much he still loses almost ten thousand dollars which is the annual salary of the head
你卖掉它，你希望价格下跌，然后你买回来并还给借给你的人，但你希望在此期间你已经获利了。这非常冒险。卖空。你做空东西，不是吗？没错。你做空东西。这非常冒险。他损失了很多钱。汤姆，他在这个时期进行了价值40万美元的交易，这是一个非凡的数字。这在当时是一大笔钱，不是吗？是的，所以你做的方法是尽量确保你不会损失太多，他仍然损失了近一万美元，这是一家大铁路公司负责人的年薪，
of a big railroad corporation i think that's the analogy that's given well he's a gambler and he's promised libby he won't gamble his wife wife. But basically, that's what he's been doing. He's lost a lot of money. He has to make our IOUs to people. And his solution is he registers with the biggest lecture agency in the country. And he wants to go on tours like P.T. Barnum and like Civil War stars and things. And he will go on tours and give paid lectures. But to do that, his currency needs to be really high. So he really needs to make his name,
我想这就是给出的类比。嗯，他是个赌徒，他答应过利比（Libby）他不会赌博，他的妻子。但基本上，这就是他一直在做的。他损失了很多钱。他必须给人们写欠条。他的解决方案是他向全国最大的演讲代理机构注册。他想去巡回演出，像P.T.巴纳姆（P.T. Barnum）和内战明星那样。他会去巡回演出并进行付费演讲。但要做到这一点，他的名气需要非常高。所以他真的需要成名，
whether it be in politics or whether it be on the frontier, but he needs to do something. And all the time, I mean, he's signed up, hasn't he, to write for magazines and... The Galaxy, yeah, exactly. The Galaxy in New York. So that's also presumably aimed at raising his profile i mean he's a very modern figure oh he is absolutely the weird thing about
无论是在政治上还是在边境上，但他需要做点什么。而且一直以来，我的意思是，他已经签约，不是吗，为杂志写稿……《银河》（The Galaxy），是的，没错。纽约的《银河》。所以这大概也是为了提高他的知名度，我的意思是，他是一个非常现代的人物。哦，他绝对是。关于卡斯特最奇怪的事情，
custer tj styles his book i have to say is absolutely wonderful on this is the way in which the perception of him is always that kind of walter scott cavalier you know dashing and he trades on that obviously but that's what he's selling yeah he sells that but the act of selling it is itself very modern and actually his end point basically i always think with custer his end game is that he's on the titanic in the first class cabins yeah that's what he wants with the asters that's where he wants to get to where i suspect he would behave very well do you think he would yeah he would escort Libby onto the lifeboats. He'd never be seen again, Tom. Just a few strands of hair drifting on the waves. His wig, his toupee, which by that point he'd definitely invested in.
TJ·斯泰尔斯（TJ Stiles）的书，我必须说，在这方面绝对精彩，就是人们对他的看法总是那种沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）式的骑士，你知道，风度翩翩，他显然利用了这一点，但这就是他所兜售的。是的，他兜售那个，但兜售的行为本身非常现代。而且实际上他的终点，我总是认为卡斯特的终局是他坐在泰坦尼克号的头等舱里。是的，这就是他想要的，和阿斯特家族（Asters）在一起，那是他想去的地方，在那里我怀疑他会表现得很好。你觉得吗？是的，他会护送利比上救生艇。他再也不会被看到了，汤姆。只有几缕头发在海浪上漂浮。他的假发，他到那时肯定已经投资了。
And he'd still be wearing, wouldn't he? Would he still be wearing a buckskin coat? Very tight buckskin trousers. Anyway, listen, Dominic, we've got to crack on. We have. Because, you know, we want to get to the fighting. But Custer doesn't get to the fighting. That's the thing. Custer at this point makes a mad decision. The Grant administration is absolutely embroiled in accusations of corruption. Historians have written loads of stuff about this. Is this a new thing? Is it a genuine thing? I mean,
而且他还会戴着，不是吗？他还会穿着鹿皮外套吗？非常紧的鹿皮裤子。总之，听着，多米尼克，我们得继续了。我们必须。因为，你知道，我们想谈谈战斗。但卡斯特没有参加战斗。这就是重点。卡斯特在这一点上做出了一个疯狂的决定。格兰特政府完全卷入了腐败指控。历史学家写了很多关于这个的东西。这是一个新事物吗？这是一个真实的事情吗？我的意思是，
partly it is a new and a genuine thing because they are quite corrupt. There are more opportunities for corruption than ever before because of the development of kind of Gilded Age politics and finance. Yeah. And because the state is bigger and it's doing more things. But at the same time, the Democrats, they're basically quite racist politicians, want to use this as a way to hit at the Grant administration over Reconstruction to say, they're also corrupt and they're giving all this money to their friends. Get back to Washington.
部分上这是一个新的和真实的事情，因为他们确实相当腐败。由于镀金时代政治和金融的发展，腐败的机会比以往任何时候都多。是的。而且因为国家更庞大，它正在做更多的事情。但与此同时，民主党人，他们基本上是相当种族的政客，想利用这一点作为打击格兰特政府重建政策的一种方式，说，他们也很腐败，他们把所有的钱都给了他们的朋友。回到华盛顿。
We don't need you in the States. And Custer decides he throws in his lot completely with the Democrats. There are hearings against the Secretary of War, William Belknap. The guy who's running the hearings, unbelievably, had been Belknap's Princeton roommate. He's a Democrat with the bizarre name of Heister Clymer. That's a wholly implausible name. So he's got these big hearings in Washington, like show trials, of Belknap. And he says they've been selling trading post positions to their friends, which they kind of have, actually. And on the 29th of March, he produces his star witness. And almost unbelievably, the star witness, who has
我们不需要你在各州。卡斯特决定他完全站在民主党一边。针对战争部长威廉·贝尔纳普的听证会正在进行。令人难以置信的是，主持听证会的家伙曾是贝尔纳普在普林斯顿的室友。他是一个民主党人，名字叫海斯特·克莱默（Heister Clymer）。那是一个完全不可信的名字。所以他在华盛顿举行了这些大型听证会，就像贝尔纳普的作秀审判。他说他们一直在把贸易站职位卖给他们的朋友，他们实际上确实这样做了。在3月29日，他传唤了他的明星证人。几乎令人难以置信的是，这位明星证人，他
clearly volunteered to do it, is Custer. So Custer goes to Washington to testify against the Secretary of War of the Grant administration. The administration that he's hoping will appoint him to the Indian command. Right. Mad. I mean, well, how Custer thinks he can get away with this? But also in Washington, he behaves in a ludicrously partisan way. He writes letters to Libby, literally from the desk of this guy, Clymer, who's running the hearings on his stationery. He has lunch with him in the restaurant at the Capitol. He goes for dinner with a load of Democrats. I mean, he's charging an enemy position without having done reconnaissance, Dominic. Yeah, he's behaving in a demented way, I think, Tom.
显然是自愿这样做的，就是卡斯特。所以卡斯特去华盛顿作证反对格兰特政府的战争部长。那个他希望任命他为印第安指挥官的政府。对。疯狂。我的意思是，好吧，卡斯特怎么认为他能逃脱惩罚？而且在华盛顿，他的行为极其党派化。他给利比写信，字面上就是从这个主持听证会的家伙克莱默的办公桌上，用他的信纸写的。他在国会大厦的餐厅里和他一起吃午饭。他和一群民主党人一起吃晚饭。我的意思是，他在没有进行侦察的情况下冲锋陷阵，多米尼克。是的，我认为他的行为很疯狂，汤姆。
So reckless. And actually, Grant and the administration are absolutely stunned by this. They can't believe that Custer would do this so flagrantly. Custer then clearly gets cold feet in roughly April. So about two weeks after he's been in Washington, we don't know, maybe somebody said something to him. Yeah. Well, he's probably, you know, the abyss has opened up before him, I would guess. Yeah. Even Custer can't think, oh, well, brilliant. Let's jump into an abyss. And actually he decides he's going to go and
太鲁莽了。实际上，格兰特和政府对此感到非常震惊。他们无法相信卡斯特会如此公然地这样做。卡斯特在大约4月显然变得胆怯了。所以在他去华盛顿大约两周后，我们不知道，也许有人对他说了什么。是的。好吧，他可能，你知道，深渊已经在他面前打开了，我会猜。是的。即使是卡斯特也不会想，哦，好吧，太棒了。让我们跳进深渊吧。实际上他决定他要去
see Grant, you know, maybe apologize that he's testified publicly against his administration. Again, demented for Custer, because he actually goes to the White House and Grant refuses to see him. He just sits outside all the time in an ante room. Yeah, of course. Not surprised. Custer decides, well, I'll just go back to the frontier anyway. I don't need to see Grant. I'll just go and I'll take up my command.
见格兰特，你知道，也许道歉他公开作证反对他的政府。这对卡斯特来说再次是疯狂的，因为他实际上去了白宫，而格兰特拒绝见他。他只是整天坐在外面的前厅里。是的，当然。不奇怪。卡斯特决定，好吧，我还是回边境去吧。我不需要见格兰特。我只是去，我会接管我的指挥权。
So he actually makes an unauthorized trip to Chicago. There, General Sheridan, who was in Chicago, receives a message from Grant that says, arrest Custer. I'm getting rid of him. He's out. So they literally pull Custer off the train. But then Custer leaks this to the newspapers, effectively. It's all so modern, isn't it?
所以他实际上进行了一次未经授权的芝加哥之行。在那里，身在芝加哥的谢里登将军收到了格兰特的一条信息，说，逮捕卡斯特。我要开除他。他完了。所以他们真的把卡斯特从火车上拉了下来。但随后卡斯特实际上把这件事泄露给了报纸。这一切都太现代了，不是吗？
He leaks it to the New York Democratic-supporting newspapers. They print the story and they say, Custer, a great hero, the best man for fighting Indians, and Grant, an American Caesar, Tom, that's what they call him, a dictator. Pulling off decorated war heroes from trains. Exactly. Disgraceful behavior. And Grant relents. And Custer sends all these telegrams to Sherman and all these people saying, please, you know, I've made a terrible mistake. Don't let my men go without me. I mean, he does the same thing that he has done all his career.
他把它泄露给了支持民主党的纽约报纸。他们刊登了这个故事，他们说，卡斯特，一位伟大的英雄，打印第安人的最佳人选，而格兰特，一位美国凯撒，汤姆，这就是他们称呼他的，一个独裁者。把受勋的战争英雄从火车上拉下来。没错。可耻的行为。格兰特让步了。卡斯特给谢尔曼和所有这些人发了所有这些电报，说，请，你知道，我犯了一个可怕的错误。不要让我的部下没有我而离开。我的意思是，他做了和他整个职业生涯中所做的一样的事情。
Do you remember back in episode one? He was court-martialed at the beginning of the American Civil War, wasn't he? Yeah. And he says, do not deny me the honor of fighting with my men. Right. He does it yet again. And as so often, he gets away with it. And actually, all his biographers say, Ulysses S. Grant, I mean, he should have had Custer
你还记得第一集吗？他在美国内战开始时被送上军事法庭，不是吗？是的。他说，不要剥夺我与我的部下并肩作战的荣誉。对。他又做了一次。而且正如经常发生的那样，他逃脱了惩罚。实际上，他所有的传记作者都说，尤利西斯·S·格兰特，我的意思是，他本应该把卡斯特
tarred and feathered. Like, Custer had been so disloyal to him. But it is this enduring theme. I mean, clearly, Sheridan still really rates him. Yeah. And the sense that the boldness, the dash. Yeah. I mean, the impetuosity you might say
涂上焦油并粘上羽毛。因为，卡斯特对他太不忠诚了。但这是一种持久的主题。我的意思是，显然，谢里登仍然非常看重他。是的。那种大胆，那种冲劲。是的。我的意思是，你可能会说那种鲁莽。
they value it i was going to say tom it's a great example of how charisma you know you can get away with a lot of sins with a bit of charisma costa has a lot of charisma and people will forgive things that had he been less dashing and swashbuckling, he would never have got away with. So off he goes to the frontier. On the 10th of May, 1876, two things happen. Number one, President Grant opens the Centennial Exhibition at Philadelphia. So this is going to be the great celebration of the United States' birthday, 100th birthday.
他们重视它。我正想说，汤姆，这是一个很好的例子，说明魅力，你知道，你可以用一点魅力逃脱很多罪过。卡斯特有很多魅力，人们会原谅那些如果他没那么风度翩翩、没那么爱冒险，他永远无法逃脱的事情。所以他去了边境。1876年5月10日，两件事发生了。第一，格兰特总统在费城开设了百年博览会。所以这将是美国生日的盛大庆祝活动，100岁生日。
And of course, victory against the Sioux and the conquest of the Black Hills would be a tremendous feather in his cap. Yeah. Happy birthday, America. It'd be a perfect birthday present. Actually, when he opens that exhibition, at which they have all these examples of modernity, Heinz Ketchup, Alexander Graham Bell's telephone, Edison has electric light. They have a Remington typewriter. They have all these things that are harbingers of the future. And at that exhibition, Grant has a very, very muted reception from the crowd. Well, they can't hear him, can they?
当然，战胜苏族（Sioux）和征服黑山将是他帽子上的一根巨大羽毛。是的。生日快乐，美国。这将是一份完美的生日礼物。实际上，当他开设那个博览会时，在那里他们有所有这些现代性的例子，亨氏番茄酱（Heinz Ketchup）、亚历山大·格拉汉姆·贝尔（Alexander Graham Bell）的电话，爱迪生（Edison）有电灯。他们有雷明顿（Remington）打字机。他们有所有这些预示未来的东西。而在那个博览会上，格兰特受到了人群非常、非常冷淡的接待。好吧，他们听不见他说话，不是吗？
They can't hear him. There's a kind of terrible wiring or whatever. Yes, exactly. The acoustics are dreadful. And so he mumbles for 10 minutes. But the political momentum is moving against him and the Republicans. He's enmeshed in scandal. And so in that sense, politically, things are looking up for Custer. They are, which is the gamble that Custer is making. So he's signalled his opposition to Grant, and he's got away with it. And I think this is on Custer's mind the whole time. It'll be on his
他们听不见他说话。有一种可怕的接线还是什么的。是的，完全正确。音响效果太糟糕了。所以他嘟囔了10分钟。但政治势头正在对他和共和党人不利。他陷入了丑闻。所以从这个意义上说，在政治上，事情对卡斯特来说正在好转。确实如此，这就是卡斯特正在进行的赌博。所以他已经表明了他对格兰特的反对，而且他逃脱了惩罚。我认为这一直在卡斯特的脑海中。这会在他的
mind. I think it was on his mind on the last day of his life that he's making this great political gamble. And it's not just that he's's making this great political gamble and it's not just that he's hoping that the tide will finally turn in his favor politically but also there is a haste yeah he's got to crack on ideally he would like to be back before the 4th of july back having won the war but definitely i think he wants to be back before the presidential election in november having won a victory so that he can play a part in that campaign. Yeah. And if the Democrats win, they'll say, thank you very much.
脑海中。我认为在他生命的最后一天，他还在想他正在进行这场伟大的政治赌博。而且不仅仅是他正在进行这场伟大的政治赌博，不仅仅是他希望潮流最终会在政治上对他有利，而且还有一种匆忙。是的，他得继续前进。理想情况下，他希望在7月4日之前回来，回来时已经赢得了战争，但绝对地，我想他希望在11月的总统大选之前回来，已经赢得了一场胜利，这样他就可以在竞选中发挥作用。是的。如果民主党赢了，他们会说，非常感谢。
He loves speed. I mean, Dash is his natural state. Yes. Kind of wandering off, charging away. And now he's got an absolute incentive to operate as fast as he possibly can. He does indeed. So he gets to Fort Lincoln. He goes to Fort Lincoln.
他热爱速度。我的意思是，冲劲是他的自然状态。是的。那种漫无目的地走，冲锋陷阵。现在他有绝对的动力以他能做到的最快速度行动。他确实如此。所以他到了林肯堡（Fort Lincoln）。他去了林肯堡。
Libby is there. The 7th Cavalry are there. His brother Tom is there. His younger brother Boston, who he employs as a forage master. Right. So he's not in the army, is he? No. And his nephew, his 18-year-old nephew, who is called Orty, Harry Armstrong Reid, his
利比在那里。第七骑兵团在那里。他的兄弟汤姆在那里。他的弟弟波士顿（Boston），他雇佣他作为草料官。对。所以他不在军队里，不是吗？不。还有他的侄子，他18岁的侄子，名叫奥蒂（Orty），哈里·阿姆斯特朗·里德（Harry Armstrong Reid），他
sister's son, and Custer employs him as a herder as well. He wants the family around him for what will hopefully be the crowning victory of his career. He's under General Terry. Terry has about a thousand men. They have Gatling guns, again, a good example of the kind of modernity of it all. So they're getting ready. It's raining the whole time. The weather is terrible. And actually the mood, Custer is quite jolly, isn't he? There's lots of accounts of him being in very good form. Very optimistic. He kind of comes back. He meets Libby.
姐姐的儿子，卡斯特也雇佣他作为牧民。他希望家人在他身边，为了他职业生涯中希望的巅峰胜利。他在特里将军手下。特里大约有一千人。他们有加特林机枪（Gatling guns），再次是这一切现代性的一个很好的例子。所以他们正在准备。一直在下雨。天气太糟糕了。实际上气氛，卡斯特相当快乐，不是吗？有很多关于他状态非常好的报道。非常乐观。他算是回来了。他见了利比。
He whisks around the room, holding her, kind of waltzing and things. Yeah. It's all great fun. As happy as a boy with a new sled, people said, when he arrived. Because Grant has allowed him to go. And would that sled be called Rosebud? Rosebud. Very good, Tom.
他在房间里飞快地转来转去，抱着她，算是跳着华尔兹之类的。是的。一切都很有趣。人们说，当他到达时，他像一个带着新雪橇的男孩一样快乐。因为格兰特允许他去了。那个雪橇会叫“玫瑰花蕾”（Rosebud）吗？玫瑰花蕾。非常好，汤姆。
Very good. He's got a new suit for the occasion, of course, hasn't he? He's got a white buckskin suit. And the members of his clique, so his brothers and their friends, they put on buckskin as well. Despite the fact that it's awful to wear in bad weather. Yeah. Gets wet and doesn't dry properly.
非常好。他当然为这个场合准备了一套新西装，不是吗？他有一套白色鹿皮西装。他的小圈子成员，也就是他的兄弟和他们的朋友，也穿上了鹿皮。尽管事实上在恶劣天气下穿它很糟糕。是的。弄湿了，不能正常晾干。
Yeah. And kind of cracks up against your skin. But the image is more important. Of course. The branding matters more than kind of practical clothes for a happy campaign. Throughout this whole thing, Custer is thinking, I think, of the brand. And he is thinking, what will my image be when I return victorious? You know, my political image. I want to appeal to investors. I want to appeal to the lecture audiences. The whole thing is very carefully calculated, I think. Although Dominic, right from the beginning, part of his brand has been his long flowing locks. He's called Long Hair
是的。而且它会在你的皮肤上产生一种粗糙感。但形象更重要。当然。对于一场快乐的竞选活动来说，品牌形象比实用的衣服更重要。我想，在整个过程中，卡斯特都在考虑品牌。他在想，当我凯旋而归时，我的形象会是什么样？你知道，我的政治形象。我想吸引投资者。我想吸引演讲听众。我认为，这一切都是经过精心计算的。尽管多米尼克，从一开始，他品牌的一部分就是他那飘逸的长发。他被称为“长发”。
by the Nature of Americans. This is very sad, Tom. Very sad story. But he is, as we've suggested already in this episode, male pattern baldness is setting in. His hair is thinning. His Samson losing his hair. It's that unfortunate look of being a balding man with a mullet. And he knows this is not a good look. And so he basically shaves it off, doesn't he? He does a Prince William. He does. He does. Well, I think it's harsh. When you're a man who's, you know, prided yourself on your hair, the hair is part of the image. To be losing that hair, that's a terrible blow for him, I think. I mean, obviously, getting a scalp would be the obvious solution.
被美国人这样称呼。这很可悲，汤姆。非常悲伤的故事。但正如我们在这集节目中已经提到的，他开始出现男性脱发了。他的头发正在变稀疏。他的参孙（Samson）正在失去他的头发。那是一种不幸的样子，一个秃顶的鲻鱼头男人。他知道这看起来不好。所以他基本上把它剃光了，不是吗？他学了威廉王子。是的，他学了。好吧，我觉得这很残酷。当你是一个以自己的头发为傲的男人时，头发是形象的一部分。失去头发，我认为对他来说是一个沉重的打击。我的意思是，显然，戴个假发套会是显而易见的解决方案。
Wearing it. Well, you know, have a toupee made up. That would be a tremendous thing, wouldn't it? If you had a toupee made up of your be i mean that would be a tremendous thing wouldn't it if you had a toupee made up of your enemies your defeated enemies yeah so a kind of constant every time you got up in the morning yeah a constant reminder to audiences of your prowess yeah anyway he doesn't do that he has it shaved off he doesn't end up in a position to do it does he tom let's be honest so the 17th of may a very very rainy, foggy, miserable day. The regiment mount their horses. The band strikes up Gary Owen, which is the Irish tune they always play
戴着它。嗯，你知道，做一个假发套。那会是一件了不起的事情，不是吗？如果你用你的敌人的头发做一个假发套，我的意思是，那会是一件了不起的事情，不是吗？如果你用你被打败的敌人的头发做一个假发套，是的，一种持续的提醒，每次你早上起床时，是的，对观众来说，不断提醒你的英勇，是的，无论如何，他没有那样做，他把它剃光了，他最终没有处于能那样做的位置，对吧，汤姆？让我们诚实一点。所以5月17日，一个非常非常多雨、多雾、悲惨的日子。团里的士兵骑上了马。军乐队奏响了《加里·欧文》（Gary Owen），这是他们总是演奏的爱尔兰曲调。
that's associated with the 7th Cavalry. Libby is allowed to go with them for the first evening. So Libby and his sister come with them that first night to the Hart River. That's about 15 miles away, 17th, 18th of May. And Custer has a sort of manservant called John Berkman who describes this scene of Libby with her arms around Custer kind of clinging to his neck in floods of tears. And then she says farewell.
这与第7骑兵团有关。利比被允许在第一天晚上和他们一起走。所以利比和他的妹妹在第一天晚上和他们一起去了哈特河。那大约有15英里远，5月17日、18日。卡斯特有一个叫约翰·伯克曼的男仆，他描述了利比双臂环绕着卡斯特，紧紧抓住他的脖子，泪流满面的场景。然后她说了再见。
Doesn't she note a kind of weird climactic phenomenon where as they ride off, they're reflected in the clouds? Yes, that's right. There's a lot of this stuff about, you know, it was very overcast and there were sort of bad omens and there was a bad feeling among the wives, which I suspect is backwards projection. I mean, Custer had ridden off to war so many times as so many of them had. I think they're conscious of this after they know the results. Yeah, okay.
她难道没有注意到一种奇怪的气候现象吗？当他们骑马离开时，他们的身影倒映在云层中？是的，没错。有很多关于这方面的事情，你知道，当时阴云密布，有一些不祥之兆，妻子们有一种不好的预感，我怀疑这是事后诸葛亮。我的意思是，卡斯特曾多次奔赴战场，他们中的许多人也是如此。我认为他们在知道结果后才意识到这一点。是的，好吧。
But I do think, Berkman says, when she finally rides off on the 18th, she looked so little and yet so young. She was leaning way over with her head bent and we knew she was crying and we watched until she was just a speck far off on the plains. And that, of course, is the last time, Tom, that Custer ever sees her. She ever sees Custer. So let's take a break there. And when we come back, curtain on entertainment and we tell you
但我确实认为，伯克曼说，当她在18日最终骑马离开时，她看起来那么娇小，却又那么年轻。她弯着腰，低着头，我们知道她在哭，我们一直看着，直到她变成平原上远处的一个小点。当然，汤姆，那是卡斯特最后一次见到她。她最后一次见到卡斯特。所以我们在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，娱乐大幕拉开，我们会告诉你
how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history and the big horn campaign is about to begin dominic yes and before we go into the details shall we just try and give listeners a sense of the overall strategic situation because we do love an overall strategic situation on the rest of history, do we not? This must run in the Holland family. Yes. So if we imagine the quarry of the army, the Lakota, the Cheyenne, the hostiles, they're in the middle of this vast expanse of the Great Plains. And Custer and Terry are marching out from Fort Abraham Lincoln, which is in Dakota. So it's east of this great kind of mass.
它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History），大角战役即将开始，多米尼克。是的，在我们进入细节之前，我们是否应该试着让听众了解一下整体的战略局势？因为我们确实喜欢在《历史的其余部分》中讨论整体战略局势，不是吗？这一定是霍兰家族的遗传。是的。所以如果我们想象一下军队的猎物，拉科塔人、夏延人、敌对部落，他们正处于大平原广阔地带的中心。而卡斯特和特里正从位于达科他的亚伯拉罕·林肯堡出发。所以它在这个巨大地块的东边。
Exactly. They're coming from the right, effectively. They're coming from the right. And so marching out, you have the 7th Cavalry, all 12 companies of it. So it's unusual for that to happen. You also have five infantry companies, the three Gatling guns that you mentioned. So they're kind of terrifying proto-machine guns, aren't they? You've got 39 Indian scouts. You've got several white scouts. You've got lots of wagons, mules, all that. So they are heading westwards. Simultaneously, our old friend Leonard Nimoy, Colonel Gibbon, who is in Fort Ellis, he is heading eastwards. He is. He's going from left to right. He's going from left to right along the line of the Yellowstone River.
没错。他们实际上是从右侧过来的。他们是从右侧过来的。所以出发时，你有第7骑兵团，全部12个连。这种情况很不寻常。你还有五个步兵连，你提到的那三挺加特林机枪。所以它们是那种可怕的原始机枪，不是吗？你有39名印第安侦察兵。你有几名白人侦察兵。你有很多马车、骡子，所有这些。所以他们正向西进发。与此同时，我们的老朋友伦纳德·尼莫伊，吉本上校，他在埃利斯堡，他正向东进发。是的。他正从左向右走。他正沿着黄石河的路线从左向右走。
Yes. So the Yellowstone River, again, is kind of flowing from the west to the east. And there are various tributaries that feed into this that are rising from the south. And in order, these are the Little Bighorn, the Rosebud, and the Powder. Yes. these are the Little Bighorn, the Rosebud and the Powder. So as you go along from Fort Ellis, along the Yellowstone, you will pass these various rivers. Yes. And the Indians are probably up one of those rivers. That's the thinking, but no one knows where. Yes. So Gibbon is heading out. He has got nine companies of infantry. So
是的。所以黄石河，同样，是从西向东流的。有几条支流从南面汇入这条河。按顺序，它们是小大角河、玫瑰花蕾河和粉河。是的，这些是小大角河、玫瑰花蕾河和粉河。所以当你从埃利斯堡沿着黄石河走时，你会经过这些不同的河流。是的。而印第安人可能就在其中一条河上。这是大家的想法，但没人知道在哪里。是的。所以吉本正在出发。他有九个步兵连。所以
that's about 450 men in all and he sets out on the 1st of april which is before custer and the 7th cavalry and terry and his gatling guns and everything have left and he is advancing along the yellowstone and he passes the little bighorn and he heads towards the rosebud which is the next river heading south and as he's doing that he meets with lakota war. So he now knows for sure that they are somewhere to the south. So you've got the 7th Cavalry and you've got Gibbon's men kind of slowly moving towards each other. And the plan is that they will rendezvous. Meanwhile, right south, you've got the Little Bighorn heading down south from the Yellowstone and the Rosebud.
总共大约有450人，他在4月1日出发，这比卡斯特和第7骑兵团，以及特里和他的加特林机枪等一切出发的时间都要早，他正沿着黄石河推进，他经过了小大角河，并向玫瑰花蕾河进发，那是向南的下一条河，当他这样做时，他遇到了拉科塔战士。所以他现在确定他们就在南边的某个地方。所以你有第7骑兵团，你有吉本的人，他们正慢慢地向彼此靠近。计划是他们会会合。与此同时，在正南面，你有小大角河从黄石河和玫瑰花蕾河向南流去。
Then you've got the Bighorn Mountains. And further south, you have Crook, General Crook. Yeah. Forked beard. With his forked beard. And he is based in Fort Fetterman in Wyoming, as it now is, Wyoming Territory as it was then. And his aim is to start moving northwards. So it's kind of like a T, isn't it? Totally. And the hope is that they will all rendezvous somewhere in the middle, find out where the hostiles are and wipe them out. Exactly. The drawback with that, you know, will these three columns be able to meet, is that they have no way of communicating with each other. No.
然后你有大角山脉。再往南，你有克鲁克将军。是的，叉胡子。带着他的叉胡子。他驻扎在怀俄明州的费特曼堡，当时是怀俄明领地。他的目标是开始向北移动。所以这就像一个T字形，不是吗？完全是。希望他们都能在中间的某个地方会合，找出敌对部落在哪里并消灭他们。没错。你知道，这三个纵队能否会合的缺点是，他们无法相互沟通。不。
Because obviously it's very, very rough terrain and it's very dangerous because there are hostile Indians out to grab you. Exactly. And not only that, Tom, even if they could communicate with each other, they're disinclined to do so because they generally... They will hate each other and jealous and resentful. Yeah, they don't really like each other. Also, I think worth saying that Terry's four, so the Dakota column, have the toughest job because Gibbon can just go along the Yellowstone, so he knows his way.
因为显然地形非常非常崎岖，而且非常危险，因为有敌对的印第安人想要抓住你。没错。不仅如此，汤姆，即使他们能相互沟通，他们也不愿这样做，因为他们通常……他们互相憎恨，嫉妒且怨恨。是的，他们真的不喜欢对方。另外，我认为值得一提的是，特里的部队，也就是达科他纵队，任务最艰巨，因为吉本可以沿着黄石河走，所以他知道路。
As Crook is going up, he has the Bighorn Mountains on his left. So again, it's quite easy for him to orient himself. Custer and everybody, I mean, it's just big sky, big plains. They've got no real idea where they are, except that Custer does because Custer is very, very good at this. So I think that's another reason why his superiors wanted Custer to be there. He probably is the one person who can get them across. Yeah. And the 7th Cavalry, so they are proceeding, as you say, very slowly. It's pouring with rain every day. It's very muddy. It's generally very miserable. And the other thing is the 7th Cavalry are very inexperienced by and large. So most of them have not seen action for years and i mean that's the veterans but about a quarter of them have never seen any action because they are very raw recruits so the people who tend to be the
当克鲁克向上走时，他的左边是大角山脉。所以同样，他很容易确定自己的方向。卡斯特和所有人，我的意思是，那只是广阔的天空，广阔的平原。他们根本不知道自己在哪里，除了卡斯特，因为卡斯特非常非常擅长这个。所以我认为这是他的上级希望卡斯特在那里的另一个原因。他可能是唯一能带他们穿过去的人。是的。而第7骑兵团，他们正如你所说，进展非常缓慢。每天都在下大雨。到处都是泥泞。总的来说非常悲惨。另一件事是第7骑兵团大多非常缺乏经验。所以他们中的大多数人多年来没有见过战斗，我的意思是那是老兵，但大约四分之一的人从未见过任何战斗，因为他们是非常生疏的新兵。所以那些往往是
most experienced the best most useful are the kind of germans and the irish and the italians and whatnot who might have seen action in europe but a lot of them have basically never fired a shot, a single shot in anger. So that's another reason why it helps to have Custer. Yeah. And of course, there's another issue. It's not just their experience, but it's that the other officers are perhaps not the ideal men to have beside you in a fight. So there are two in particular, aren't there?
最有经验、最好、最有用的，是那些德国人、爱尔兰人、意大利人等等，他们可能在欧洲见过战斗，但他们中的许多人基本上从未在愤怒中开过一枪，连一枪都没有。所以这是需要卡斯特的另一个原因。是的。当然，还有另一个问题。不仅仅是他们的经验，而是其他军官可能不是你战斗时身边最理想的人选。所以特别有两个，不是吗？
So the first of these, Captain Bentine, we've met before. Our old friend, Captain Bentine. Yes. I mean, i mean i think we agreed before tom that he was a very then his personality seemed very admirable and interesting but yeah very reminiscent of a certain presenter on this podcast so he's been with custer a long time he was at the washita yeah you know he's a seasoned indian fighter yeah but he blames Custer for having behaved badly at the Washita. If Custer was bleeding to death on the other side of the pavement, Bentin would walk the other way. Bentin is ultimately an affable yet malignant man. That's fair, isn't it? It's Bentin. Affable yet malignant. Yeah. A strange combination that one never comes across.
所以第一个是本廷上尉，我们之前见过。我们的老朋友，本廷上尉。是的。我的意思是，我想我们之前同意过，汤姆，他是一个非常……他的个性看起来非常令人钦佩和有趣，但是的，非常让人想起这个播客的某位主持人。所以他和卡斯特在一起很长时间了，他在瓦希塔。是的，你知道他是一个经验丰富的印第安战士。是的，但他指责卡斯特在瓦希塔表现得很糟糕。如果卡斯特在人行道的另一边流血致死，本廷会走另一条路。本廷最终是一个和蔼可亲但又恶毒的人。这很公平，不是吗？这就是本廷。和蔼可亲但又恶毒。是的。一个奇怪的组合，人们从未遇到过。
But he's also incredibly brave. I just want to put that on the record. Yeah, a strange combination that one never comes across. But he's also incredibly brave. I just want to put that on the record. Yeah, he is. So he's tremendously brave. And actually, in a pinch, although he will try to betray you and get you killed at first, when it comes to it, he will probably save your life. But also weirdly, I mean, he has the look of a male musical performer playing a duchess, which is also quite odd. He does. He does. Yeah, he does. Anyway, he has the look of a male musical performer playing a duchess, which is also quite odd.
但他也非常勇敢。我只是想把这一点记录在案。是的，一个奇怪的组合，人们从未遇到过。但他也非常勇敢。我只是想把这一点记录在案。是的，他是。所以他非常勇敢。实际上，在紧要关头，虽然他起初会试图背叛你并让你送命，但当真正需要时，他可能会救你的命。而且奇怪的是，我的意思是，他看起来像一个扮演公爵夫人的男性音乐表演者，这也非常奇怪。他确实是。他确实是。是的，他确实是。无论如何，他看起来像一个扮演公爵夫人的男性音乐表演者，这也非常奇怪。
He does. He does. Yeah, he does. Anyway, so that's Captain Benteen. Yeah. But then his immediate superior and Custer's second in command is a guy called Major Marcus Reno. Yeah. And he's a decorated officer from the Civil War.
他确实是。他确实是。是的，他确实是。无论如何，这就是本廷上尉。是的。但他的直接上级和卡斯特的副手是一个叫马库斯·里诺少校的人。是的。他是内战中获得勋章的军官。
He is. Yeah. But he's never really engaged with Native Americans either. I mean, he's not an Indian fighter either. He's a character, yeah but he's never really engaged with uh with native americans either i mean he's not an indian fighter either it's a character isn't he he was at west point with uh the painter whistler james mcneil whistler yeah astonishing and reno made a great joke with whistler didn't he so whistler did abysmally in his exams at west point well he was like you he didn't have any time for science right what's the thing he got wrong? Something about silicon? He said that silicon was a gas. And Whistler is supposed to have said to Reno some years later
他是。是的。但他从未真正与美洲原住民交战过。我的意思是，他也不是印第安战士。他是一个角色，是的，但他从未真正与美洲原住民交战过。我的意思是，他也不是印第安战士。他是一个角色，不是吗？他和画家惠斯勒，詹姆斯·麦克尼尔·惠斯勒一起在西点军校。是的，令人震惊。里诺和惠斯勒开了一个很棒的玩笑，不是吗？惠斯勒在西点军校的考试中表现极差，好吧，他就像你一样，他没有时间学习科学，对吧？他弄错了什么？关于硅的事情？他说硅是一种气体。几年后，惠斯勒应该对里诺说过
that if silicon truly had been a gas, as Whistler had claimed, then he probably would have stayed in the army and become a major general. And Reno said, yes, but then nobody would ever have heard of your mother. Because of course, Whistler's famous painting is of his mother. So he got failed. He got flung out of West Point because he failed his science and went off and painted his mother. Yeah. That is Reno's joke.
如果硅真的是一种气体，正如惠斯勒所声称的那样，那么他可能就会留在军队里并成为一名少将。里诺说，是的，但那样就没人会听说你的母亲了。因为当然，惠斯勒最著名的画作是他母亲的画像。所以他不及格了。他因为科学考试不及格而被踢出了西点军校，然后去画了他的母亲。是的。这就是里诺的笑话。
It is the one joke that he makes in the course of his entire career because he's an unbelievably miserable, somber man. So the scouts call him the man with the dark face. If anything can go wrong for him, it will. But he has had terrible luck. He was orphaned as a teenager. Both his parents died. And then he was happily married, but then his wife died, leaving him with a 10-year-old
这是他在整个职业生涯中讲的唯一一个笑话，因为他是一个令人难以置信的悲惨、阴郁的人。所以侦察兵称他为“黑脸人”。如果有什么事情会对他出错，那一定会出错。但他运气极差。他十几岁时就成了孤儿。他的父母都去世了。然后他曾有过幸福的婚姻，但后来他的妻子去世了，留下了一个10岁的
boy who's brought up by her family. So he's just, his life's in ruins. But this is an example of it, that every time something looks as if it's going well, it doesn't. And he is a man who's naturally suspicious. So although he was decorated in the Civil War, he did have a very traumatic experience where he led a troop of men into an ambush. All right. He's never recovered from that. So that might have had a scarring effect on him that may have a role to play in it. There's a lot of drinking going on with him. Yes, exactly. He drinks very heavily. Yeah. He's a lot of drinking going on with... Yes, exactly. He drinks very heavily. Yeah. He's a man who basically feels incredibly sorry for himself because fate has dealt him some terrible cards.
男孩，由她的家人抚养长大。所以他只是，他的生活一片狼藉。但这就是一个例子，每次事情看起来进展顺利时，结果却不然。他是一个天生多疑的人。所以虽然他在内战中获得过勋章，但他确实有过一次非常痛苦的经历，他带领一队人马陷入了伏击。好吧。他从未从中恢复过来。所以这可能对他产生了创伤性的影响，可能在其中发挥了作用。他喝了很多酒。是的，没错。他喝得很厉害。是的。他喝了很多酒……是的，没错。他喝得很厉害。是的。他是一个基本上对自己感到非常同情的人，因为命运给了他一些糟糕的牌。
He's a Jonah. He is a total Jonah, isn't he? If he was on a ship, he would be a Jonah. You'd throw him off, wouldn't you? Yeah. He'd bring you bad luck. That's what they should have done. I feel sorry for Reno, but they should have shot him before they...
他是个“约拿”（倒霉鬼）。他是个彻头彻尾的“约拿”，不是吗？如果他在船上，他会是个“约拿”。你会把他扔下去，不是吗？是的。他会给你带来厄运。这就是他们应该做的。我为里诺感到难过，但他们应该在他……之前就枪毙他。
But Custer, meanwhile, he's full of larks. He's gadding around. He's got his brothers with him. Yeah. He's got four hunting dogs. It's full of larks. He's gadding around. He's got his brothers with him. He's got four hunting dogs. It's all great larks. Yeah, and at first he annoys Terry, doesn't he? Because he keeps going off with his brothers and the dogs. Well, because Terry's dependent on him to show the way.
但卡斯特，与此同时，他兴高采烈。他到处闲逛。他带着他的兄弟们。是的。他有四只猎犬。他兴高采烈。他到处闲逛。他带着他的兄弟们。他有四只猎犬。一切都非常开心。是的，起初他惹恼了特里，不是吗？因为他总是带着他的兄弟和狗到处跑。好吧，因为特里依赖他来指路。
And so they all get lost. And then Custer comes back and Terry bollocks him. But Terry still likes him. Yeah, because eventually Custer gets them through the badlands of the Dakota territory and so they reach the Powder River to the Powder River and from there Terry is able to go down to the confluence of the Powder River and the Yellowstone and there we did say he loved a steamer a steamship a paddle steamer yeah so he's on his steamship so the far west steamer is waiting for him which Nathaniel Philbrick says is not just a boat, but a movable island of American culture where Terry could enjoy a gaslit dinner on China plates and a clean tablecloth.
所以他们都迷路了。然后卡斯特回来了，特里训斥了他。但特里仍然喜欢他。是的，因为最终卡斯特带他们穿过了达科他领地的荒地，所以他们到达了粉河，从那里特里能够前往粉河和黄石河的交汇处，在那里我们确实说过他喜欢汽船，蒸汽船，明轮蒸汽船，是的，所以他在他的蒸汽船上，所以“远西号”蒸汽船正在等他，纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克说这不仅仅是一艘船，而是一个移动的美国文化岛，特里可以在那里享受瓷盘上的煤气灯晚餐和干净的桌布。
Because that is how we would want to wage a war. It is. If I was Benteen-like, I'd be busy betraying my fellow officers and glorying in their downfall. But so Terry gets on the boat. He goes along the Yellowstone River. Colonel Gibbon has come on ahead of his troops coming from the other side, from the west. They get together, they have a conference. And Gibbon says, you know, my scouts think that there definitely is an Indian village
因为这就是我们想要发动战争的方式。确实。如果我是本廷那样的人，我会忙于背叛我的同僚军官，并为他们的垮台而沾沾自喜。但特里上了船。他沿着黄石河走。吉本上校已经先于他的部队从另一边，从西边赶来了。他们聚在一起，开了一个会议。吉本说，你知道，我的侦察兵认为肯定有一个印第安村庄
and it's probably somewhere along the Rosebud. So just to remind listeners, so it's south. Yeah, south of where we are. And it's the Bighorn, furthest west, then the Rosebud, and then the Powder. Yeah. And he's saying, yeah, it's either the Bighorn or it's the Rosebud, somewhere around there. It's somewhere around there. We don't know where.
而且它可能就在玫瑰花蕾河沿岸的某个地方。所以提醒一下听众，它在南边。是的，在我们所在位置的南边。它是大角河，最西边，然后是玫瑰花蕾河，然后是粉河。是的。他说，是的，要么是大角河，要么是玫瑰花蕾河，就在那附近。就在那附近。我们不知道在哪里。
It seems quite large. They seem to be traveling away. Well, because they have to, don't they? Because the larger it is, the more they need game and water and grass to feed everyone. They need to keep finding buffalo, the Lakota. That's why they're always on the move. And of course they need water, which is why you can assume that they're on a river. Yeah. So Terry finally says to Gibbon, right, you go back to your men, keep coming. We'll keep coming. We'll eventually somehow trap them between us so we'll be able to maybe turn south or maybe general crook is coming up you know northwards as we hope because they're not sure of
它看起来相当大。他们似乎在远离。好吧，因为他们必须这样做，不是吗？因为规模越大，他们就越需要猎物、水和草来喂养每个人。他们需要不断寻找水牛，拉科塔人。这就是为什么他们总是在移动。当然他们需要水，这就是为什么你可以假设他们在河边。是的。所以特里最终对吉本说，好吧，你回到你的人那里，继续前进。我们会继续前进。我们最终会以某种方式把他们困在我们之间，所以我们也许能转向南，或者也许克鲁克将军正像我们希望的那样向北走，因为他们不确定
that are they no they don't know because they're not communicating with crook at all because of course terry and crook despise each other and refuse to communicate so terry goes back to custer custer's been waiting just sitting his tent, writing his articles for the Galaxy. And Terry says, right, they're definitely there somewhere. What we're going to do is I'm actually going to send out Reno with some scouts on a reconnaissance mission. Custer doesn't like this idea at all. Custer is furious at this.
他们不确定，不是吗？不，他们不知道，因为他们根本没有和克鲁克沟通，因为当然，特里和克鲁克互相鄙视，拒绝沟通。所以特里回到卡斯特那里，卡斯特一直在等，只是坐在他的帐篷里，为《银河》杂志写文章。特里说，好吧，他们肯定就在那里的某个地方。我们要做的实际上是派里诺带一些侦察兵去执行侦察任务。卡斯特一点也不喜欢这个主意。卡斯特对此非常愤怒。
And he lets everyone know he doesn't like it, doesn't he? Sends an anonymous letter to the New York Herald. That is such Custer behaviour. But he's not wrong, is he? Because basically it's going to hold everybody up. Yeah, it's massive dithering and delay. And Custer's in a hurry. He's in a hurry. So Reno is going to go off. And Reno's under
他让每个人都知道他不喜欢这个主意，不是吗？给《纽约先驱报》写了一封匿名信。这真是典型的卡斯特行为。但他没错，不是吗？因为基本上这会拖慢所有人的速度。是的，这是巨大的犹豫和拖延。而卡斯特很着急。他很着急。所以里诺要出发了。而里诺在
very clear instructions. You don't go and fight these Lakota. What you should do is find out where they are, then come straight back and tell us. Of course, Reno is going to, as everyone will expect, to completely ignore this and to go way beyond his remit and he's meant to stick really to the rosebud but he goes beyond that doesn't he now meanwhile you may be thinking what about that third army under general crook well they are kind of trudging north there's about a thousand of them and they will come up against the Lakota first, won't they?
非常明确的指示下。你不要去和这些拉科塔人战斗。你应该做的是找出他们在哪里，然后直接回来告诉我们。当然，里诺会像每个人预期的那样，完全无视这一点，远远超出他的职权范围，他本应真的只待在玫瑰花蕾河，但他超出了那个范围，不是吗？现在，与此同时，你可能在想，克鲁克将军领导的那第三支军队怎么样了？好吧，他们正蹒跚向北，大约有一千人，他们会先遇到拉科塔人，不是吗？
Because the Lakota, their numbers have swollen. They are moving all the time. There are about 460 lodges by the beginning of June 1876. I mean, this is probably larger than any assembly. Yeah. Maybe in the entire history of the plains. Exactly. Maybe in that big agreement they had at Laramie, possibly.
因为拉科塔人，他们的人数增加了。他们一直在移动。到1876年6月初，大约有460个帐篷。我的意思是，这可能比任何集会都要大。是的。也许是平原历史上最大的。没错。也许是在拉勒米达成的那个大协议中，可能。
Yeah, one of the Fort Laramie, exactly, when they signed one of those treaties. But otherwise, I mean, this is on an unprecedented scale. So by the end of May, that village has camped near the mouth of the Rosebud, hasn't it? Rosebud Creek. And sitting Bull Scouts have told him there are American troops somewhere. They are coming. And the younger warriors in particular are very keen for a fight. Of course they are. There are so many of them. For the first time in their history, they have a genuine chance of actually attacking US Army. Normally the US Army attack them, but this is a chance to attack
是的，拉勒米堡，没错，当他们签署其中一项条约时。但除此之外，我的意思是，这是前所未有的规模。所以到5月底，那个村庄已经在玫瑰花蕾河口附近扎营了，不是吗？玫瑰花蕾溪。坐牛的侦察兵告诉他，美国军队在某个地方。他们来了。年轻的战士们尤其渴望战斗。当然他们是。他们有这么多人。这是他们历史上第一次有真正的机会攻击美国军队。通常是美国军队攻击他们，但这却是一个攻击
a sizable American force. And they'd actually have quite good odds of winning. So they're really keen. And they have never done that before. No. And so this also will be a factor that certainly crooks Colin by surprise. Totally surprised. Because when the attack comes, he's not expecting it at all. And I think the two leaders that we've been talking about throughout this series,
一支相当大的美国军队的机会。而且他们获胜的几率实际上相当不错。所以他们真的很渴望。而且他们以前从未这样做过。不。所以这也将是一个因素，肯定会让克鲁克的纵队感到惊讶。完全惊讶。因为当攻击来临时，他根本没有预料到。而且我认为我们在整个系列中一直在谈论的那两位领导人，
first of all, Sitting Bull. So he has a vision and he does a sun dance. So that's, you know, sticking hooks through his flesh and blowing on a whistle. They gouge out 50 pieces of flesh out of his arms. Yeah. And he dances for two days and two nights. They gouge those little kind of divots of flesh, 50 of them on each arm. So he, I mean, he is plunged into this kind of extreme of pain and exhaustion. And he has this vision that an army will be coming from the East and that it will be destroyed. But I think by this point, it's clear they know that Crook's army is also coming from the South. And this encourages the braves to think, let's go and have a crack. And there's no question that the person who's behind that strategy is Crazy Horse.
首先是坐牛。所以他有一个幻象，他跳了太阳舞。所以那是，你知道，把钩子穿过他的肉，吹着哨子。他们从他的手臂上挖出了50块肉。是的。他跳了两天两夜。他们挖出了那些小块的肉，每只手臂上50块。所以他，我的意思是，他陷入了这种极端的痛苦和疲惫之中。他有一个幻象，一支军队将从东方而来，它将被摧毁。但我认为到这一点，很明显他们知道克鲁克的军队也正从南方而来。这鼓励了勇士们去想，让我们去试一试。毫无疑问，那个战略背后的那个人是疯马。
Yeah. Crook is useless, isn't he? I mean, Crook, this experienced Indian hand, you know, the great frontiersman and whatnot. He is brooding. He's very unhappy about this whole expedition. And he actually just spends all his time playing whist with um with some of the other officers at one point a group of allies american allies arrive and these are the shoshone people and the crows crows of course the great enemies of the um of the dakotas with
是的。克鲁克没用，不是吗？我的意思是，克鲁克，这个经验丰富的印第安老手，你知道，伟大的边疆开拓者等等。他正在沉思。他对整个远征非常不满意。他实际上只是把所有时间都花在打惠斯特牌上，和一些其他军官在一起。有一次，一群盟友，美国盟友到达了，这些是肖肖尼人和克罗人，克罗人当然是达科他人伟大的敌人，有
a fondness for bear grease hair pomade with their gre. Yeah. And they have an amazing fellow with them called Frank Gruard, who is Sir Harry Flashman's illegitimate son, Tom. Yes, that's right. Yes. Or is he? But in reality, he's a South Sea Islander. He's from Polynesia. His father had been a Mormon missionary.
对熊油发蜡的喜爱。他们有一个了不起的家伙和他们在一起，叫弗兰克·格鲁阿德，他是哈里·弗莱什曼爵士的私生子，汤姆。是的，没错。是的。或者他是吗？但实际上，他是一个南太平洋岛民。他来自波利尼西亚。他的父亲曾是一名摩门教传教士。
He'd been born in Polynesia, then come back. Various mad adventures. He'd been adopted by some Mormons, then captured by the Sioux, adopted by Sitting Bull as his brother. Yeah. Amazing. And ends up as a scout for the US Army. Yeah. And he's saying, look, there are enormous numbers out there. Yeah. Enormous numbers. Be careful. But Crook ignores it because he despises them. Yeah. Mad. He doesn't think it's going to happen. But what both Sitting Bull and I think especially Crazy Horse, their genius at this point is that they hold back. They wait for the opportunity because under normal circumstances, there wouldn't be a kind of massive, massive entity. So that when finally, on the 17th of June, the attack comes, in vast numbers. Crook unbelievably carries on playing cards. He says, oh, this is obviously Tosh. They would never do that. And it's only when the bullets start flying that he's like, oh my God, they are coming. And then this battle goes on
他在波利尼西亚出生，然后回来。各种疯狂的冒险。他被一些摩门教徒收养，然后被苏族人俘虏，被坐牛收养为兄弟。是的。太神奇了。最终成为美国军队的侦察兵。是的。他说，看，外面有大量的人。是的。大量的人。小心。但克鲁克无视它，因为他鄙视他们。是的。疯了。他不认为这会发生。但坐牛和我认为尤其是疯马，他们此时的天才在于他们克制住了。他们等待机会，因为在正常情况下，不会有那种大规模的实体。所以当最终，在6月17日，攻击来临时，人数众多。克鲁克令人难以置信地继续打牌。他说，哦，这显然是胡说八道。他们永远不会那样做。直到子弹开始飞，他才说，哦，我的天，他们来了。然后这场战斗持续了
for six hours, which never happens. For six hours? It's never happened before. Never happens. Normally it's just a lightning attack and then the Indians are gone. So there's a journalist at the battle and he says, so closely did the Indians approach our skirmishers at times that they inflicted several wounds from battle axes, lances, and arrows. And in one or two instances, they closed in upon a brave soldier and got his scalp before comrades could rush forward to the rescue. You imagine six hours of that. It's going to have quite a demoralizing effect, isn't it? Utterly grueling. Even though Crook doesn't lose that many men, his morale is completely shattered. He loses the support of the allies, the Shoshonas and the Crows.
六个小时，这从未发生过。六个小时？以前从未发生过。从未发生过。通常只是闪电战，然后印第安人就走了。所以战斗中有一名记者，他说，印第安人有时非常接近我们的散兵，以至于他们用战斧、长矛和箭造成了几处伤口。在一两个例子中，他们围住了一名勇敢的士兵，并在战友们冲过来救援之前割下了他的头皮。你可以想象六个小时的这种战斗。这会产生相当大的挫败感，不是吗？极其艰苦。尽管克鲁克没有损失太多人，但他的士气完全崩溃了。他失去了盟友肖肖尼人和克罗人的支持。
They just think, well, Crook is totally useless. I mean, I have no respect for him at all. The squaw chief, they call him. Yes. And they're the squaw chief. And then he says to his men, well, we obviously can't continue with this. I mean, let's just stay where we are. So he stops advancing.
他们只是认为，好吧，克鲁克完全没用。我的意思是，我对他一点尊重都没有。他们称他为“娘娘腔酋长”。是的。他们是“娘娘腔酋长”。然后他对部下说，好吧，我们显然不能继续这样了。我的意思是，我们就待在这里吧。所以他停止了前进。
Now, this is important because if you go back to your strategic picture, there were meant to be like three arrows moving in from different directions. But now one of them is defunct because it's stopped. Crook gives up and he basically has a massive holiday. He goes fishing. He collects birds. He plays more cards. He actually goes on a sort of a glamping trip.
现在，这很重要，因为如果你回到你的战略图景，本应有三支箭从不同方向射入。但现在其中一支已经失效了，因为它停止了。克鲁克放弃了，他基本上度过了一个巨大的假期。他去钓鱼。他收集鸟类。他打更多的牌。他实际上去进行了一次类似豪华露营的旅行。
I mean, Dominic, I've been there. It's nice. The Big Horn, you know, the vicinity of the Big Horn Mountains, gorgeous. Yeah. You know, if I was given the choice between being scalped or kind of hanging out by the Big Horn Mountains, I know what I'd go for. Well, that's what General Crook, and he was an experienced frontiersman, so you're in very good company.
我的意思是，多米尼克，我去过那里。那里很不错。大角，你知道，大角山脉附近，非常漂亮。是的。你知道，如果让我选择是被剥头皮还是在大角山脉附近闲逛，我知道我会选什么。好吧，这就是克鲁克将军的选择，他是一位经验丰富的边疆开拓者，所以你和非常优秀的人在一起。
Well, yeah. But crucially, the absolute folly, he doesn't tell anybody. He could have sent a horseman to look for General Terry and to say, I've stopped coming. And by the way, there are clearly far more of them
好吧，是的。但关键是，绝对的愚蠢，他没有告诉任何人。他本可以派一名骑兵去寻找特里将军，说，我停止前进了。顺便说一句，显然有更多的人
and they're much more aggressive than any sort of plains natives that we've ever encountered. And much more coordinated. But he doesn't natives that we've ever encountered and much more coordinated but he doesn't do that so actually in the meantime reno's been doing his scouting he's gone roaming around the country for much longer than was planned because he's ignored his orders custer is just sort of hanging around with his dogs in his tent writing for the galaxy writing for the press yeah i mean custer at Custer at one point, he finds an abandoned Lakota camp, doesn't he? He's sort of roaming around a little bit.
而且他们比我们遇到过的任何平原原住民都要激进得多。而且协调得更好。但他没有这样做，所以实际上，与此同时，里诺一直在进行侦察，他在乡间游荡的时间比计划的要长得多，因为他无视了他的命令。卡斯特只是带着他的狗在帐篷里闲逛，为《银河》写作，为媒体写作。是的，我的意思是卡斯特，在某一点上，他发现了一个废弃的拉科塔营地，不是吗？他有点在到处游荡。
He finds an abandoned camp. And there's a burial ground there. And he and his brothers and some of their friends desecrate the graves. Yeah. They take moccasins and trinkets. I mean, you'd never want to do that to an Indian burial ground. Well, some of his men say this is A, very bad behaviour, but B, it risks a curse.
他发现了一个废弃的营地。那里有一个墓地。他和他的兄弟们以及他们的一些朋友亵渎了坟墓。是的。他们拿走了鹿皮鞋和饰品。我的意思是，你永远不会想对印第安墓地做那种事。好吧，他的一些部下说这A，是非常糟糕的行为，但B，它冒着诅咒的风险。
Yeah, this is the kind of thing that you do shortly before you're massacred. Never do this. So even at the time, some people think, well, this is foolish. Anyway, Reno finally comes back
是的，这是你在被屠杀前不久会做的那种事。永远不要这样做。所以即使在当时，有些人也认为，好吧，这是愚蠢的。无论如何，里诺最终回来了
on the 21st of June. They all get together on General Terry's steamer. He's still on his steamer, Tom, eating like, you know. With his tablecloths and croissant. Crab cocktail. Like rack of lamb. Champagne.
在6月21日。他们都聚在特里将军的蒸汽船上。他还在他的蒸汽船上，汤姆，吃着，你知道。带着他的桌布和羊角面包。蟹肉鸡尾酒。像烤羊排。香槟。
They get together on the steamer. And there is some talk there. Well, there are rumors that this is a very, very large Indian encampment. But of course, they've heard nothing about Crook's defeat on the Rosebud. They think he's still coming and they think he's still out there. And the thing that obsesses them all is the fear that the native encampment will break up and they will get away. Yeah, because that's the crucial thing, isn't it? They want to find as large a group of people as possible.
他们聚在蒸汽船上。那里有一些谈话。好吧，有传言说这是一个非常非常大的印第安营地。但当然，他们对克鲁克在玫瑰花蕾河的失败一无所知。他们认为他还在赶来，他们认为他还在外面。让他们所有人着迷的是担心印第安营地会解散，他们会逃走。是的，因为那是关键，不是吗？他们想找到尽可能大的一群人。
Yeah. The larger it is, the better. It never occurs to them. It's extraordinary. It literally never occurs to them until i would guess custer is gazing down this two mile long village i don't even think at that point tom i think it's you know it's like an hour before he dies yeah that it occurs to them they might actually lose up to that point there are so few hints of self-doubt or fear it's extraordinary i mean they're talking all the time about exactly how we'll get rid of all these people how we'll round
是的。越大越好。这从来没有出现在他们的脑海中。这太不可思议了。我猜直到卡斯特凝视着这个两英里长的村庄，它字面上从来没有出现在他们的脑海中，甚至在那一点上，汤姆，我想那是他死前一小时，它才出现在他们的脑海中，他们可能会输。在那之前，几乎没有自我怀疑或恐惧的暗示，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，他们一直在谈论到底我们将如何摆脱所有这些人，我们将如何围捕
them all up how we'll smash them but it never occurs to them that they're actually you know any sporting encounter there's another team that might win and of course the person who is the embodiment of that attitude is custer and it is decided that Custer should be unleashed. Yeah. So essentially the 7th Cavalry. So leave the infantry behind. Custer turns down the chance to take the Gatling guns because he says they'll slow him down. Well, they will.
他们，我们将如何粉碎他们，但从来没有出现在他们的脑海中，他们实际上，你知道，任何体育比赛都有另一支球队可能会赢。当然，那种态度的化身就是卡斯特，于是决定应该释放卡斯特。是的。所以基本上是第7骑兵团。所以把步兵留在后面。卡斯特拒绝了带加特林机枪的机会，因为他说它们会拖慢他的速度。好吧，它们确实会。
They are very heavy. Yeah, of course they will. And for him, speed is of the essence because he wants his victory in time for the centennial. He is also offered for extra cavalry companies who are commanded by an officer called James Sanks Brisbane. And he really doesn't want to go with Custer. And he says to Terry, General, you have more sense in your little finger than Custer in his whole body. Basically, you should be leading it. You're much better than Custer would be. And Terry says, wow, you don't seem to rate Custer at all.
它们非常重。是的，当然它们会。对他来说，速度是至关重要的，因为他想在百年纪念时获得胜利。他还被提供了四个额外的骑兵连，由一位叫詹姆斯·桑克斯·布里斯班的军官指挥。他真的不想和卡斯特一起去。他对特里说，将军，你的小指头里的智慧都比卡斯特全身的智慧多。基本上，你应该领导它。你比卡斯特好得多。特里说，哇，你似乎一点也不看好卡斯特。
And he says, I don't rate him at all. I think he's terrible. But Terry loves Custer's swash, his buckle. Yeah, also, Terry loves that steamer, Tom. Of course, of course. Yeah, but that's the point of Custer's swash, his buckle. Also, Terry loves that steamer, Tom. Of course. Of course. Yeah, but that's the point of Custer. There's no point in taking him and not unleashing him, right?
他说，我一点也不看好他。我觉得他很糟糕。但特里喜欢卡斯特的浮夸，他的那种劲头。是的，而且，特里喜欢那艘蒸汽船，汤姆。当然，当然。是的，但这就是卡斯特的浮夸的意义所在。带上他而不释放他毫无意义，对吧？
Exactly. I mean, that's what he's for. What's the point of having him otherwise? Yeah. And so Terry says, I'm going to send Custer, and he'll take all of the 7th Cavalry. But obviously I need to give him orders, and I need to give him orders that no matter what happens,
没错。我的意思是，他就是为此而生的。否则带他有什么意义？是的。所以特里说，我要派卡斯特去，他将带上所有的第7骑兵团。但显然我需要给他命令，我需要给他命令，无论发生什么，
I won't look bad. Yeah. But I think we think that's about General Terry's orders because it all went badly wrong, and we think that he was trying to cover himself. But also, you could argue the orders have a sufficient degree of flexibility in them that he can allow Custer to react as he sees fit. Well, but the thing is, Dominic, basically he's saying, don't be headstrong. But at the same time, he knows what Custer to react as he sees fit. Well, but the thing is, Dominic, I mean, basically he's saying, you know, don't be headstrong. But at the same time, he knows what Custer's going to do. And the rule is, the rule of engagement throughout this period, if you're in the US Army, is that if you find a village, you attack it. Because always the risk is that it will go off. You know, it's kind of pinning something that is always buzzing around.
我都不会看起来很糟糕。是的。但我认为我们认为那是关于特里将军的命令，因为一切都变得非常糟糕，我们认为他是在试图保护自己。但你也可以争辩说，这些命令中有足够的灵活性，他可以允许卡斯特根据他认为合适的方式做出反应。好吧，但问题是，多米尼克，基本上他是在说，不要固执己见。但同时，他知道卡斯特会做什么。而且规则是，这一时期美国军队的交战规则是，如果你发现一个村庄，你就攻击它。因为风险总是它会跑掉。你知道，这就像钉住某种总是嗡嗡作响的东西。
Exactly. So the plan basically is that Custer will march south, up the Valley of the Rosebud. He will find the trail of the Lakota and Cheyenne camp. He'll push them west, and then he'll drive them up to the north. And meanwhile, Terry will eventually, once he's finished his dinner, be coming down south. So they will trap them between them. That's the plan, isn't it? But Terry leaves enough ambiguity in the orders. There's one lieutenant, Lieutenant Bradley, put it in his diary. It's understood that if Custer arrives first, he is at liberty to attack at once if he deems it prudent. And I think everybody expects that Custer will do that because they know Custer. Bradley says, we have little hope of being in at the death as Custer will undoubtedly exert himself to the utmost to get there first and to win all the laurels for himself
没错。所以计划基本上是卡斯特将向南行进，沿着玫瑰花蕾河谷。他会找到拉科塔和夏延营地的踪迹。他会把他们向西推，然后把他们赶向北方。与此同时，特里最终，一旦他吃完晚餐，就会向南走。所以他们会把他们困在中间。这就是计划，不是吗？但特里在命令中留下了足够的模糊性。有一位中尉，布拉德利中尉，把它写进了他的日记。人们理解，如果卡斯特先到达，如果他认为审慎，他有权立即攻击。我认为每个人都预料到卡斯特会这样做，因为他们了解卡斯特。布拉德利说，我们几乎没有希望在死亡时在场，因为卡斯特无疑会竭尽全力先到达那里，并为自己赢得所有的荣誉。
and his regiment. There's a kind of exchange between him and Gibbon. Yes. The Gibbon says, you know, give us a chance to do something. Yeah. And Custer kind of gives an enigmatic reply where it's not clear whether he's saying, yeah, I will leave you to do it or no, I'm definitely going to have a crack. That's right. Don't be greedy, but wait for us. And Custer says, no, I will not. What does that mean? And what's he referring to? You're not going to wait or you're not going to be greedy. And he kind of chuckles. The weird thing is that that night before he leaves, so he leaves, they have their last party. The soldiers all get drunk. The officers are playing poker on the steamer. But Custer, his servant John Burtman said, he was very subdued. He sat up writing, just sort of staring out at the river. He wasn't the life and soul of the party as he often was. And I wonder whether some people say, did Costa have a foreboding? I don't think he did have a foreboding. I think he's under a lot of pressure. He's got money problems. He's got political problems. He's got massive money problems. Exactly. He's got to get this right. And actually getting it right means it's not a question of not losing. It doesn't ever occur
以及他的团。他和吉本之间有一种交流。是的。吉本说，你知道，给我们一个机会做点什么。是的。卡斯特给出了一个模棱两可的回答，不清楚他是在说，是的，我会让你们去做，还是不，我肯定要自己去尝试。没错。别贪心，但要等我们。卡斯特说，不，我不会。那是什么意思？他指的是什么？你不会等，还是你不会贪心？他笑了笑。奇怪的是，在他离开前的那天晚上，他们举行了最后的聚会。士兵们都喝醉了。军官们在汽船上玩扑克。但卡斯特，他的仆人约翰·伯特曼说，他非常低沉。他坐着写东西，只是盯着河面看。他不像往常那样是聚会的灵魂人物。我怀疑有些人会说，卡斯特是否有预感？我不认为他有预感。我认为他承受着巨大的压力。他有经济问题。他有政治问题。他有巨大的经济问题。没错。他必须把这件事做好。实际上，做好意味着这不是一个不输的问题。从来没有人想过
to anybody that he's going to lose. It's a question of not letting any of them get away. Sitting bull, crazy horse, they can't get away. And not letting anyone else share in the spoils of victory. Yes, exactly. Exactly. So at midday on the 22nd of June, Custer says farewell to the other officers. He has that exchange with Gibbon that we described, and then off he goes. And they march for 12 miles.
他会输。问题是不让任何一个人逃脱。坐牛、疯马，他们不能逃脱。也不让其他人分享胜利的果实。是的，没错。没错。所以6月22日中午，卡斯特向其他军官告别。他与我们描述的吉本进行了那次交流，然后他就出发了。他们行军了12英里。
His officers are struck that evening when they camp that he seems very preoccupied. He's almost humble in the way he talks to them. He says, now, listen, if you have ideas, I will want to hear them. I trust your judgment. I trust your discretion. Please don't squabble with each other. I mean, this is obviously directed at Benteen. We don't want backbiting.
那天晚上他们扎营时，他的军官们感到震惊，因为他似乎非常心事重重。他在与他们交谈时几乎表现得很谦逊。他说，现在，听着，如果你们有什么想法，我想听听。我相信你们的判断。我相信你们的谨慎。请不要互相争吵。我的意思是，这显然是针对本廷的。我们不希望背后中伤。
We don't want sniping. We've got to work together on this. And some of his lieutenants say, this isn't like Custer at all. Why is he so, is he depressed? Is he anxious? And one of them actually says, Lieutenant George Wallace says to his friend, Lieutenant Godfrey, it's like custer's luck is going to run out again but i mean you don't think this is kind of backdated well that
我们不希望互相攻击。我们必须在这件事上通力合作。他的一些中尉说，这根本不像卡斯特。他为什么这么……他是抑郁了吗？他是焦虑了吗？其中一个人，乔治·华莱士中尉对他的朋友戈弗雷中尉说，这就像卡斯特的运气又要用完了，但我的意思是，你不认为这是事后诸葛亮吗？好吧，那
hangs over all these exchanges and all these so-called omens and premonitions and foreshadowing isn't it tom did this really happen i think it's plausible that custer was preoccupied there are enough accounts of him sure but i think you're right i don't think that's because he thinks he's going to die. No. He's just worried about, you know, he's got a lot of irons in the fire and he wants to make sure that they're all lined up. But I mean, one thing that we can absolutely date is a letter that Libby Custer writes to Custer, who she calls Autie, like all his family do. Oh, Autie, how I feel about you going away so long without our hearing your safety is ever in my mind my thoughts my dreams my prayers are all for you god bless and keep my darling ever your own libby in other circumstances that would be a very moving letter
笼罩在所有这些交流和所有这些所谓的预兆、预感和伏笔中，不是吗，汤姆？这真的发生了吗？我认为卡斯特当时心事重重是合理的，关于他的记载足够多，当然，但我认为你是对的，我不认为这是因为他认为自己会死。不。他只是担心，你知道，他有很多事情要处理，他想确保一切都安排妥当。但我的意思是，有一件事我们可以确定日期，那就是利比·卡斯特写给卡斯特的一封信，她称他为奥蒂，就像他所有的家人一样。哦，奥蒂，想到你要离开这么久，而我们却听不到你的消息，我心里总是担心，我的思绪、我的梦想、我的祈祷都是为了你，上帝保佑并守护我的爱人，永远是你自己的利比。在其他情况下，那会是一封非常感人的信
but not read like that but it is a very moving letter because of course she writes that on the 22nd of June. And at that point, Tom, her husband has just three days left to live. Right. And in our next episode, the battle of the little bighorn will be joined. So if you want to find out what happens, whether Custer gets his victory, who knows what's going to happen, you can get that immediately by joining us at therestishistory.com and signing up there, where you get a whole
但读起来不像那样，但这确实是一封非常感人的信，因为当然，她是6月22日写的。那时，汤姆，她的丈夫只剩下三天生命了。没错。在我们的下一集里，小大角战役将会打响。所以如果你想知道发生了什么，卡斯特是否取得了胜利，谁知道会发生什么，你可以通过加入therestishistory.com并注册立即获得，在那里你会得到一个
host of additional benefits, don't you, Dominic? A whole host. Unbelievable host, yeah. Or you can just wait. You'll still get it, but you might just have to wait a bit and listen to some of our wonderfully produced adverts as well. Madness to wait there, wouldn't it? As Custer would tell you, speed is all. Speed is all, Tom.
大量的额外福利，不是吗，多米尼克？大量的。难以置信的大量，是的。或者你可以等一等。你仍然会得到它，但你可能只需要等一会儿，并听听我们制作精良的广告。等待太疯狂了，不是吗？正如卡斯特会告诉你的，速度就是一切。速度就是一切，汤姆。
You wouldn't want to wait. Yeah, it is. Speed and dash. Although, I mean, spoiler alert, didn't entirely work out for him. So either way, we'll see you very soon for the climactic battle of this extraordinary story. Bye-bye. Bye-bye bye-bye
你不会想等的。是的，确实。速度和冲劲。虽然，我的意思是，剧透预警，对他来说并不完全奏效。所以无论如何，我们很快就会在这个非凡故事的决定性战役中见到你们。再见。再见，再见。
i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。